qué tal buenas noches y el movimiento al
socialismo que es el que ha presentado
esta demanda de la persona de la ex
diputada lidia para ti sostiene que
cuando el ex presidente evo morales ha
renunciado a su cargo en noviembre de
2019 lo ha hecho en realidad porque ha
habido un golpe de estado perpetrado por
los opositores en concomitancia con los
jefes militares y policiales tal es así
que durante estas jornadas se han
producido operativos en diferentes
partes del país para detener a los ex
ministros y también a los ex jefes
militares por ejemplo han sido detenidos
y a los ex ministros de energía rodrigo
guzmán el ex ministro de justicia álvaro
coimbra y se ha buscado durante esta
jornada a yerko núñez ex ministro de la
presidencia los ex ministros de defensa
y de gobierno ya se encuentran fuera de
bolivia ellos han salido el año pasado
en la previsión de que el retorno del
movimiento al socialismo al poder podría
significar una persecución para ellos
así es marc y le pregunto hasta el
momento cuál han sido las reacciones en
torno a todo lo que está ocurriendo
bueno la oposición ha reaccionado
indignada ha señalado que se trata de
una persecución brutal en contra del
gobierno transitorio de jeanine áñez y
que busca en el fondo tapar el fraude
electoral que según ellos cometió evo
morales para prorrogarse en el poder en
contra de la constitución política del
estado recordemos que el año 2019 la
organización de estados américanos ha
establecido que en bolivia se produjo un
fraude electoral en favor del ex
presidente morales los opositores
aseguran que este es el motivo por el
que en este momento el gobierno de luis
arce y también de evo morales que es el
jefe del movimiento al socialismo busca
tapar esa irregularidad con una demanda
de golpe de estado por otro lado debo
comentarles que los opositores
consideran que la fiscalía y la justicia
bolivianas se encuentran al mando en
realidad respondiendo al gobierno de
luis arse existe coincidencia tanto de
analistas como de políticos
en sentido de que la justicia y la
fiscalía responde al gobierno de turno
tal como lo hizo con evo morales ya
tiene años y ahora con luís arse